dark souls 1 is a fantastic game it's
got a wonderful story that would set in
motion numerous events that would occur
throughout the trilogy but with just
within the bounds of its own game dark
souls 1 has some incredibly deep and
rich lore filled with some of the
greatest backstories this series has to
offer and today i want to discuss why so
without further ado
let's get started so the opening
cinematic of dark souls 1 starts at the
gray world one that is filled with giant
trees and dragons and while the world
stayed like that for a while one day
fire was born as for how this fire came
to be well it's never explained this is
one of the many things we just have to
accept the world of dark souls is
fantasy and many things just can't be
explained it's never mentioned how the
first flame was created as it just
happened but because the first flame was
born disparity came with it life and
death heat and cold and light and dark
this description is literal since the
first flame was created the people of
the world felt its warmth and understood
what heat was when they walked away from
the flame they realized its heat didn't
reach them which created the feeling of
cold the discovery of fire during the
stone age is to this day the greatest
discovery known to man and in dark souls
this is no different given how unique
something like this in the world of dark
souls was those who discovered it were
obviously attracted to its power four
notable people would discover lord souls
next to these flames and be given
immense power these people were neato
izalith gwyn and the pygmy from the
intro we can infer that there was a
civilization of people that existed
during the age of ancients izalith had
daughters that were with her when she
found her lord's soul and gwyn had his
nights with him implying that people did
exist during the time of the age of
ancients but weren't of much value to
the world given how powerful the dragons
were eventually neato izalith and gwyn
would band together and use their power
to overthrow the dragons gwyn used this
lightning izalith used her flames and
nito used his death and disease they
also received help from a seath the
scalists a dragon who betrayed his own
kind now that the new lords were on top
of the food chain the age of ancients
was no more and the age of fire had
begun this period would last thousands
of years until we get to today currently
the fire is fading and it needs to be
rekindled in order to keep it lit but
doing this is not as simple as it sounds
you may have noticed i forgot to talk
about the pygmy well the pygmy had a
unique soul called the dark soul using
his soul he created something called
humanity he would then share this
humanity with his people these dark soul
imbued people became known as humans the
pygmy is essentially our ancestor gwyn
feared this power though and created the
dark sign which inadvertently caused the
undead curse this isn't explained much
in dark souls 1 but it is by far the
most important plot in the whole series
and while i just wanted to talk about
this game for the whole video this needs
to be explained or else the rest of the
video going forward will make no sense
the undead curse the dark sign and the
fading of the fire are all linked the
dark soul gets more powerful the closer
the fire is to fading thus meaning
humans should get more powerful over
time but gwyn screwed humanity twice by
rekindling the flame thus removing our
chance at power but also by branding
humans with the dark side think of this
as a literal wall of fire that prevents
the dark soul within men from getting
too powerful the dark side only
activates when the flame is fading
because that is when the dark soul
within men starts to grow stronger this
dark sign also prevents humans from
dying but it also causes them to go
undead these fleshy creatures were once
undead humans but they have crossed the
barrier of no return even though humans
are able to revive after death
eventually this will cause them to lose
their humanity lose their minds and lose
their purpose causing them to go hollow
these creatures are hollows beings who
don't even remember who they are where
they are or what they're even doing gwyn
likes being on top and he fears the day
that he will lose his power so he'll do
anything he can to prevent that from
happening he did this by branding
humanity with the dark side but by also
rekindling the flame which is known as
the first sin see the world is like a
set of operations things are born but
eventually they'll die but then more
things will be born only to die soon
after that's just the way the world
works but gwyn broke the laws of the
world by rekindling the first flame it
was meant to be extinguished but due to
gwyn wanting to hold on to what he held
dear he couldn't dare see it go he
sacrificed himself by using himself as
kindling for the first flame since he
had one of the four original lord souls
that came from the first flame it was
deemed sufficient enough to be used as
fuel unless the gauge of fire continued
but as we know it is fading once more
the undead curse is back humans are
turning hollow and the world is in chaos
doesn't this sound like a fantastic
story
that's because it is this intro and even
the game display a sense of desperation
within our characters how far people
willing to go to get what they want or
keep what they have and while each of
their desires is different it always
comes out the same dark souls 1 is just
the start but the actions of its
characters will continue to echo
throughout the entire trilogy and we're
just getting started after the opening
cinematic we get to see the state of the
world as it is today or at least the
state of this prison we're an undead
that is sitting in their cell awaiting
the end of the world but one day we're
given the key to our cell and are able
to leave this person is oscar and he
speaks of a prophecy there is an old
saying in my family
thou who art undead are chosen and thine
exodus from the undead asylum maketh
pilgrimage to the land of ancient lords
when thou ringeth the bell of awakening
the fate of the undead thou shalt know
this prophecy also happens to be the
main objective of the game but it's only
the first part the rest we'll have to
discover later the intro of dark souls 1
sets up a new world by showcasing
multiple important events in the world's
history and also gives us enough
information to understand the basic
premise of the game while also purposely
withholding some of that information to
give us a reason to seek out said
information one thing we need to
consider though is our character's
motivations why even bother making the
trip to lordran the land of lords well
what else is there to do it's the end of
the world and you were just given the
keys to your cell allowing you to
explore the world to your heart's
content even if you're convinced that
life is doomed in the world as we know
it will disappear for good why not make
the most out of it have some fun kill
some hollows it's a whole lot better
than rotting in a cell with our
objective laid out to us thanks to oscar
we can now set out to lordran and ring
the bells technically the first area
you're meant to go is the undead burg
but one wrong step and you can make it
to new londo out of all the souls games
dark souls 1 will provide the best blind
playthrough as due to its connected
world players will go in different
directions which in turn will create
different experiences new londo is
actually a late game area since the
enemies here are quite strong and the
boss at the end of the level is quite
tough but you may stumble upon this area
by accident within five minutes of
arriving this is due in part to dark
souls ones a level design which may have
the best level design in the whole
franchise it's been coined as a
metroidvania a genre that started with
the game's metroid and castlevania these
games have non-linear progression as
many areas can be accessed right away
but others can't causing the player to
go around the map looking for the key
then running back to that same location
such as this door that leads to havel
which can only be found in the dark
route basin past the boss the door is
found pretty early on in your
playthrough but the key is found much
later plus you'll also have to remember
where that key goes you'll be doing lots
of running in this game the highlight of
one of my play sessions was going from
blighttown to andre because i forgot to
ascend my weapon before a boss fight
meaning i had to take a three minute
walk up to him then a three minute walk
back down in future titles this would be
remedied by fast travel but dark souls 1
doesn't have fast travel initially and
even when you do gain the power of fast
travel via the lord vessel it's not the
typical fast travel we're familiar with
as we're only allowed to travel to
specific bonfires these decisions
further immerse the player into the
world as it's all one connected level
and since they're all connected that
means you can see certain levels from
different places such as blighttown
which is visible from firelink shrine so
not only was the level design of each
area taken into account but also how the
levels connected to one another and how
this connection would affect other areas
regardless of where you end up though
whether that be new londo or undead berg
the very first enemies you'll come to
see are these hollow men like the ones
back in the asylum all the undead we see
here are humans who have lost their
humanity causing them to go hollow and
now since we are human we should go
hollow too however it's a bit more meta
than that hollowing is a bit hard to
define as everyone can go hollow for
different reasons but the two main ideas
seem to stem from constant death or a
loss of purpose given that our character
is set on ringing the bells he never
goes hollow despite being undead as he
still has a purpose should the player
quit and uninstall the game they would
lose their purpose so permanently
quitting the game is sort of like
hollowing in a sense i don't think
everything needs to be explained with
lore so this is more than likely just a
gameplay mechanic but that's how i've
interpreted hollowing on our way to the
bells of awakening will come across
various different locations but sadly
there isn't a whole lot of backstory
involved in their creation locations
like undead burg are just undead
settlements and the valley of drake's is
just a valley filled with drakes the
only exceptions though are ash lake and
blighttown blighttown is next to a
location called the depths and at the
end of the depths is the gaping dragon
and while an interesting boss what's
more important is the arena we can see
water coming from the depths and going
into the sewer system which leads to
blighttown according to various keys in
the game we can piece together that
those who previously lived in the undead
burg but were banished from the
settlement were sent to blighttown as
punishment this is reinforced by the
giant door that separates the sewer
system from the outside world but this
water from the sewer is poisonous well
in blighttown there's a spell called
poison mist and according to its
description it seems that enki this
egg-bearing individual may have caused
this as he was the creator of the poison
miss spell it's not fully confirmed that
he did this but it's clear that
blighttown isn't in the greatest state
and it's due to the circumstances
surrounding blighttown that the
townsfolk seem to have built above the
water in hopes of getting away from it
this is a common theme in these games of
things being built on top of one another
as we see blighttown above the swamp
depths above blighttown and the undead
burg above all that the idea of pushing
things down and leaving them to fester
is also a common theme within this game
but not everything is in such a sad
state as at the lowest point of lordran
we see ash lake a seemingly infinite
land filled with archeries that are
surrounded by an equally infinite body
of water for the purposes of asha lake
this seems to be where the dragons used
to live for at least one part of it as
it's eerily similar to the environment
in the intro which we do know was the
land of the everlasting dragons we can
even find one of the few remaining
dragons down here in ash lake he's a
part of the dragon covenant in-game and
from various descriptions it seems like
many people worship the dragons and
tried to ascend to their level it's
unclear though if that worked once the
player feels confident in their fighting
abilities they can approach the bosses
defending the bells of awakening these
being the bell gargoyles and chaos witch
quailag after bringing both bells we'll
see that sen's fortress a place that was
originally blocked with a large gate is
now open but if we travel back to
firelink shrine we'll find a primordial
serpent named frant he claims to be a
close friend of gwynns and also claims
to know our fate
very well
then i am pleased to share
chosen undead
your fate
is to succeed
the great lord gwyn
so that you may link the fire
cast away the dark
and undo the curse of the undead
to this end
you must visit anor londo
and acquire the lord vessel just like
before this second part of the prophecy
also happens to be our newest objective
but frampt is quite a complex character
if certain conditions are met within the
game we can also be granted an audience
with coth he however tells us a
different story your ancestor claimed
the dark souls
and waited for fire to subside
and soon
the flames did fade
and only dark remained
thus began the age of men
the age of dark
so it wasn't just the fact that the fire
was fading that caused gwen to rekindle
it the flame actually went out
furthermore despite being the same
species both frampt and koth have
different views on the world frant wants
to keep the age of fire going but koth
wants to usher in an age of darkness the
question is who do we trust
well that's up to you as these are the
two endings of the game extinguish the
flame or rekindle it the choice is yours
what is important to note though is
their motivations why are they doing
this why are they against each other
well we still don't know and it's been a
widely debated topic that hasn't been
given a proper answer yet regardless i
don't think you should trust any of them
frampt claims that the undead curse will
be cured if we link the flame but this
isn't correct as we'll see in dark souls
2 and 3 the curse is still present
frampt and koth are like politicians
they say what needs to be said but never
elaborate by technicality the undead
curse will be cured when we link the
flame as we know the dark side only
appears when fire fades and if it's not
fading then the curse of the dark sign
is gone which means the curse goes with
it but it will eventually come back
things are meant to run their course so
over time the fire will fade again and
the curse will come back just not in our
character's lifetime frampt whether
intentional or not is leading the player
to believe that the curse will disappear
permanently when indeed it only just
disappears for a few thousand years but
koth is also lying as he isn't fully
explaining what this age of darkness
entails and as we'll see koth isn't
exactly the nicest person in the soul's
universe i've always seen these two as
immortal beings ones that are ageless
and due to this when the time comes they
like to move the pieces a bit and see
what happens koth and frampt are
basically playing a long game of chess
but without the stakes regardless of who
wins they both continue to live one just
managed to convince the chosen undead
more so why not cause a bit of chaos a
liar to hear wouldn't hurt anybody as
it's just extra pieces on the board to
them to this day we still don't know
what they really want from us and
whether their goals they conveyed to us
were actually genuine my interpretation
of these could be wildly incorrect but
that's the beauty of these games they
allow you to shape your own story and
create your own adventure and in my
story i don't trust these two regardless
of who you believe the one thing they
agree on is that we need the lord vessel
thus we need to get to anor londo to get
there we'll need to pass through sen's
fortress a place filled with deadly
traps and is easily the most infuriating
area in the whole game the fortress is
also used as a sort of trial as this
leads us to anor londo but many people
have tried and failed to get there this
is of course due to the numerous traps
throughout the fortress and the iron
golem at the top although he was
surprisingly the easiest part of the
fortress once the golem is defeated we
are then grabbed by these demons and
taken to anor londo
god
[Music]
it's hard to forget your first time in
anor londo nothing up until this point
has been more extravagant and beautiful
looking than this place and that's what
makes it so memorable in a world devoid
of beauty and color there's this
incredible place that just exists but
it's on the other side of the wall but
something is off it feels empty like we
showed up late to a party and in a more
metaphorical and literal sense we have
this place is gorgeous but if you'll
excuse the pun it's also quite hollow
lots of your time and anor londo is
spent walking but if you manage to make
it past these giants and exploit the ai
of these silver knights then you'll make
it to the climactic fight of ornstein
and smoke ons is undoubtedly my favorite
fight in dark souls 1. the balance of
these two is unmatched as orenstein is a
quick nimble fighter that can go halfway
across the arena just to hit you but his
damage is nowhere near as staggering as
the force that is smo where as ornstein
instills fear from his speed smo's fear
comes from his power ornstein at the
beginning of the fight is more or less a
pushover he does deal decent damage but
it's not enough to warrant a healing
item but no amount of damage resistance
especially this early on could protect
you from spoe's hammer and one hit from
this hammer can make orenstein seem a
lot more threatening their power grows
from the other's presence as the more
ornstein chips at your health the closer
you are to being within one shot range
of smoke and if smoke hits you once well
there's nothing that can compare to that
level of stress they feed off each other
in such a balanced way in fact they
actually feed on each other as whoever
falls first becomes the power source for
the other their health also goes back to
full so it's never about dwindling them
down over time it's committing to one
and sticking with it the problem is
knowing when to strike and how given how
well they complement each other it might
seem like there's never an opening and
that's what makes them such a difficult
fight all that's required though from
the player is patience it's arguably one
of the best fights in the game and even
the series as a whole and i can finally
see why while ons may seem like the
climactic finish to the level hold your
load as behind them is the real climax
the princess of sunlight guinevere
feel free to interpret climax however
you want she is the one who gives us the
lord vessel we need to progress through
the game but as i said earlier it feels
like we arrived late to a party well i
wasn't lying once the post not clarity
settles in if we attack gwynevere the
world of anor londo shows its true
colors and reveals that it's just as
depressing as everything else in lordran
and the one responsible for this
illusion is dark sun gwyndolin gwyndolin
is an interesting case to me as he was
the last born child of gwyn who was a
male but was raised as a female this was
due to his strong affinity with moon
magic i'm not sure what the connection
is but maybe it's some sort of cultural
thing where the moon is seen as a sort
of feminine symbol which would actually
explain a lot regarding a future game
and two of its characters gwyndolin also
created the illusion of anor londo to
seemingly entice the chosen undead to
continue their duty remember gwyndolin
only appears when we kill gwenevere's
illusion meaning that this is actually
gwyndolin speaking to us through his
sister he also shares the same
viewpoints as frampt which is
interesting as he's basically telling us
to kill his father and continue the age
of fire gwindelin seems to want to hold
on to the power his family has and keep
things running smoothly which is why he
wants the age of fire to continue so
that his family and their powers can
stay and the reason why he created the
illusion of anor londo was also to
desperately hold on to the past
ah i guess it runs in the family then as
for how gwenevere fits into this while
she was gwyn's second born child who
like many other deities left in orlando
she would then meet with a flame god
flan and later become his wife besides
these two gwen had two other children
but we'll have to wait for dark souls 3
to discuss more about them so in orlando
the city of gods this place that was
supposed to be seen as a beacon of hope
to all within lordran is just an
illusion but anor londo isn't the only
illusion of lordran but making our way
to the painting inside the city upon
touching it were thrown into the painted
world of ariamis ariamus as a concept is
fascinating as it's this world within a
world and these people inside the
painting could possibly never know of
the world outside of it from exploring
this hidden world we learned that
ariamis was made for things the gods
feared ariyamas is home to the followers
of velka and velka is known as the
goddess of sin furthermore this is the
only location in the game where you can
find the dark ember which according to
its item description is used to make
occult weaponry weapons that were
favorable amongst those who plan to kill
the gods and their kin velka was more
than likely someone who wanted to hunt
the gods but was killed or thrown into
the painting it's clear that this place
has a malicious history behind it but
it's not all bad as the person who
watches over ariemus is crossbreed
priscilla priscilla is a half-human
half-dragon crossbreed due to this
unique birth she also gained some unique
abilities mainly the ability of lifehunt
which she uses on her scythe these
powers of hers could threaten the god's
rule so they also threw her into the
painted world but what's rather
interesting is priscilla herself she's
the only boss in the game that doesn't
want to fight us she even tells us how
to leave ariamus meaning not only does
she have no intent of enacting revenge
but she knows how to leave yet refuses
priscilla may have felt how these new
arrivals feel but instead of using
vengeance she uses acceptance and
instead welcomes these people into her
painted world it's actually quite
wholesome and is the reason why i
couldn't kill her every boss in this
game is hell-bent on killing me so when
i finally discovered one that didn't
want to and in fact help me i couldn't
refuse so i left with the hope that
priscilla would be able to make this
place a proper home for her people this
whole area is swarming with hollows and
other creatures that want nothing more
than to kill us but they were either
tricked into here or thrown in because
the gods willed it and yeah some of them
probably do belong in here but if
priscilla is set on making this place a
home for those who have found themselves
here then who am i to intervene after
acquiring the lord vessel when we meet
with koth or frampt they'll tell us that
to gain access to gwyn we must gather
the remaining lord souls and use them to
satiate the lord vessel these lord souls
belong to four individuals seat the
scalists the witch of izalith nito and
the four kings three of whom you will
have already recognized from here we can
tackle the game in any order we want so
let's start with the four kings the four
kings are well four kings who ruled over
new londo they were given fragments of
gwyn's soul which is why we need to kill
them you may recognize their boss
location as this is the same dark abyss
that we met kathan well long ago the
four kings were tricked by koth and were
consumed by the abyss this caused the
kings to go mad and this also caused the
citizens to either become these blobs of
mass or the dark wraith soldiers this
area really utilizes the environment to
tell its tail as this place is overrun
by the ghosts of the villagers and when
we actually unlock the door to lower new
londo we see piles of corpses scattered
throughout the land koth single-handedly
destroyed an entire city simply by
tricking its inhabitants and unleashing
the abyss upon them while the mass
extinction of a city sounds bad there is
still more destruction to be seen one
thing you may have noticed is a severe
lack of human bosses quailag would
probably count as the first one you'd
meet although she's sort of half human
but there's a reason for this as this
has to do with the witch of izalith
while gwyn was frantically running
around trying to figure out what to do
with the flame the witch of izalith had
a plan she was going to create a new
flame that would replace the first flame
but she attempted to create a replica in
the presence of the very thing that was
created which brought with it massive
consequences the witch of izalith wanted
to create a new first flame but there
was already a first flame present in the
world there can't be two first flames
due to this the flame that she created
couldn't be contained for long causing
it to erupt and this not only consumed
her and her children but also created
new life as it gave birth to demons the
asylum taurus and capra demon roughly
the first three bosses in the game were
created from this event in fact anything
that has the word demon in it is most
likely derived from this flame of chaos
but not only was new life created old
life was altered all of eisele's family
who were caught in the explosion were
all transformed into demons themselves
chaos which quailag the fair lady and
ceaseless discharge are three of
izalith's children just as gwyn was
desperate to continue the age of fire in
an attempt to keep what he had so too
did izalith but the consequences are a
reflection of her actions in an attempt
to give life to something bright and
warm she ended up giving life to
something cold and dark she also wanted
to extend the age of fire in order to
continue her prosperous life with her
children but by doing so she ended up
making their lives a living hell not a
single person in this family tree is
living a robust life anymore quailag and
her sister the fair lady are half demon
and are more than likely suffering from
their condition as told to us by the
fair lady
what is it
quail egg
my dear sister the eggs
it hurts
they've gone still
i am afraid
it may be too late
i am so sorry
dear sister
cecilia's discharge was covered in lava
source from birth so his life was a
living hell from the start the flame of
chaos just made it worse ceaseless
discharged just like priscilla doesn't
actually want to fight us it's only
until we steal this clothing set that he
attacks us this clothing set rests upon
a grave that belonged to his sister
quelana who he believes died in the
explosion when in fact she was the only
one who escaped quelana will appear in
blighttown if the player is sufficient
enough in pyromancy quelana explains
that she was the only one who made it
out of the reaches of the flame of chaos
in fact she was actually able to harness
the power of the flame of chaos and
create magic which we know as pyromancy
quilana wants us to fulfill her duty for
her as she does not have the strength to
go on she instructs us that we need to
put down her siblings and her mother so
that they may rest in peace this whole
family dynamic is horrific as ceaseless
believes that all his sisters are dead
even though kwalana is alive and quelana
is only a few meters from her sister and
yet we can tell her about this clearly
this is turning into a very depressing
story but it only gets worse as we get
closer to the final boss of the area
we'll meet with a pyromancer who is
assumed to be another daughter of izalit
although it's unclear why she is so far
down in these ruins yet is completely
unharmed it's possible that she like
kweilana escaped the flame of chaos but
this daughter came back to finish off
the boss right behind her or has
possibly gone insane and is now
defending said boss and by going down
this slide we will meet this monstrosity
who is the bet of chaos this is the
witch of izalith one of the four most
powerful people in the world has been
demoted to this deformed tree-like
creature there are also these orbs next
to her that we need to destroy in order
to damage her and it's assumed by many
that these are her other two daughters
that were closest to her when the flame
erupted so we have two daughters stuck
to their mother two daughters who were
half afflicted by the flame a son who is
arguably the most affected and two
daughters who manage to survive one who
doesn't have the strength to carry on
anymore and another who sits outside her
mother's arena this is by far the most
depressing story i've ever had the
misfortune of uncovering the further we
push into lost izalith the more of the
family we get to meet allowing us to see
the consequences of her actions we can
see the pain that all of them are in as
some of them are just wishing for their
siblings back and others just want to
stay alive it's an awful story that all
leads to the final fight with izalith
herself and it is by far
the most anticlimactic ending i've ever
experienced it is agreed upon by many
that the bet of chaos is the worst fight
in dark souls 1. the boss is insanely
difficult but it's not the difficulty
itself that's the issue it's why the
boss is difficult i would argue that
just within the main game the two
hardest bosses are the four kings and
ornstein and smoke ons are difficult
bosses because there's two of them you
have to have both on screen at all times
or you'll lose this fight this is
balanced by having orenstein be fast but
not as lethal and smo being slow and
hard-hitting it's a wonderful dichotomy
that makes for a satisfying fight and
the four kings is a dps check as every
30 to 45 seconds a second king will
spawn and this will keep going until 4
on your screen at once to succeed you
need to kill the current king before
this happens both boss fights are hard
but have weaknesses you can exploit the
bet of chaos has none to defeat the boss
you need to destroy both orbs on her
sides then go down the middle inside of
her so you can find the source of her
power she's actually extremely weak as
both the orbs and her die on one hit
it's getting there that's the issue her
hand attack is oddly timed and due to
her design it's unclear where her hitbox
ends after defeating one of the orbs the
floor will start to crumble so not only
do you need to avoid her attacks but
you'll also need to avoid the floor
there's also a strict path you're meant
to follow for this fight which will lead
you right next to a broken piece and the
flooring so you'll more than likely get
hit and fall in and die the walk back to
this boss is also just as atrocious as
you'll more than likely spend more time
walking to the boss than actually
fighting her thankfully there is no
reset involved in this boss as every
single run you've done is carried over
to the next as it essentially has
unlimited checkpoints it's like from
software knew it was bad but still kept
it in even if i actually enjoyed the
fight the payoff narratively isn't worth
the time we ventured further and further
into the depths of lost izalith coming
across all of her children who were
these hideous beasts that did incredible
damage and she's just a puzzle the witch
of izalith has one of the best
backstories in the game as the tale of
her children is heartbreaking and being
able to see their conditions face to
face does take a lot out of you but it's
completely soured by a boss fight that
is mechanically and narratively a
letdown our third lord soul belongs to
grave lord nedo and he's
interesting to say the least nido might
have the most detailed boss design but
the most basic story out of all the four
lords if you were to just assume that
nito simply became the grim reaper and
just administered death you wouldn't be
far off which is a shame for someone of
his importance gravelord nido lives in
the tomb of giants which is accessed via
the catacombs both these areas share a
similar theme of death as this is where
the dead are buried so we know that he
administers death but what else does he
do well
not much else he does have a covenant
that you can join but their goal is just
to spread more death across the world it
seems like he doesn't care about what's
going on in the world as the only reason
he attacks you is because we're
obviously here with malicious intent
nido doesn't have any lore regarding his
life during the age of fire and it's
just about him administering death from
this we can infer that nito either
doesn't care about the age of fire or
maybe even just wants the age of
darkness to occur the only other bit of
lore surrounding him is a boss named
pinwheel who is a necromancer presumably
made up of three people as referenced by
the number of masks on the body who
stole an item from him known as the rite
of kindling there are quite a few
theories regarding pinwheel like the
fact that pinwheel was originally a
father but his wife and child died so he
attempted to resurrect them but it
failed and some have stated further that
he's still trying to figure out how to
revive them as we can see skeletons
throughout the room which could be seen
as his test subjects but other than that
we've pretty much discussed all of nito
there isn't anything else to speak about
which is a real shame his backstory has
a massive amount of potential but it
just felt unfinished there are no major
themes tied to nito he just kinda exists
our final lord soul belongs to seath
descales seath as we remember allied
himself with our four lords and attacked
the dragons the reason he did this was
because seath unlike the other dragons
was not immortal all the other dragons
had impenetrable scales that could not
be broken with any type of weapon sheath
was not born with these scales so in a
sense he was not immortal it was only
until gwyn was given their weakness from
sith which we know is lightning that
gwyn was able to pierce the dragon's
scales and actually kill them seath was
envious of his brethren as they had what
he didn't so as thanks for working with
gwyn he was named the duke and given the
duke's archives as well as some of
gwyn's lord soul for power during the
war seath found the primordial crystal
an item that gave him temporary
immortality but during this time in the
duke's archives he eventually went mad
with his experiment in his research he
is considered the grandfather of sorcery
as well as the creator of these
creatures and the moonlight butterfly
our first interaction with seath is that
he ends up killing us and throwing us in
a prison cell we can see that theme of
desperation as seath is trying
everything he can to get what he wants
but in the process it made him mad he's
not as mindful of his actions as he used
to be in a sort of a shadow of his
former self one thing i find interesting
in this prison is the abundance of
miracle-related items and the clothing
that are scattered throughout the prison
it's possible that clerics were deemed
suitable subjects for seath experiments
maybe this is due to their magical power
or because they were so easy to defeat
to kill seath though we need to head to
the crystal caves which i was originally
going to say was probably the worst
level in this game due to half the map
being invisible but the walk to the boss
is surprisingly straightforward
venturing off that path though is where
the problem lies to defeat seath we need
to break his primordial crystal so that
we can sever his immortality giving us a
chance to kill him the story of these
lords caused a bit of an imbalance
throughout my playthrough you can go
through lost izalith and the demon ruins
which is filled with rich lore tons of
backstory and compelling bosses that fit
with the lore surrounding the witch of
izalith but then you go to the four
kings and just find out that they were
lords of new londo who got tricked by
koth and consumed by the abyss it feels
jarring going from one to the other as
one feels thorough while the other feels
incomplete like you missed something or
there was more that should have been
said i don't think every boss needs to
have a multi-page wikipedia article in
order for it to be considered a good
story i think that the boss's story said
what needed to be said in regards to the
overarching plot but i can't lie to you
and tell you that i didn't leave these
locations wanting more i wanted to know
more about the four kings and how they
rose to power and i wanted to know more
about nito and seath in general but i
never got that and i guess in a way this
could be viewed as a positive as i
didn't walk out of these places not
wanting to learn them at all but rather
wanted to learn more the game invested
me so much into its story thanks to its
characters and environmental
storytelling that i wanted the game to
provide me with more information on it i
wanted to be encapsulated by this story
more than i already was as with many
souls games not all answers are
explicitly told to us but there were
still a lot of burning questions i had
that never got mentioned with the lord
souls on the vessel we are now able to
fight gwyn but we still have one final
location we need to visit which is the
land of oolacile accessed by the
artorius of the abyss dlc the one and
only dlc that dark souls 1 would have we
start this dlc by defeating this gold
golem that has a woman named dusk
captured inside dusk was the princess of
a place called oolacile according to her
it's a place from an age that existed
long ago hilariously enough she doesn't
actually say anything after this you
would think that the dlc would sort of
spin a story that her home is in danger
and we need to save her but she doesn't
actually tell us that she just sells us
sorceries the dlc doesn't officially
start though until we return back to her
location with an item called the broken
pendant which causes us to get sucked in
into this portal and taken to oolacile
as dusk said ulysses was a place from
long ago and while you may be confused
on how this fits within the geography of
lordran this place is a lot closer than
you think in fact we already ran through
it to get to the dlc the dark rouge
garden is oolusil this is evident by the
tree enemies who have a similar design
to these tree-like enemies and the same
plants that are only found in the dark
root garden are also found here as well
oolusio was a city hundreds of years
before the dark rouge garden came to be
so something happened that made this
place turn into the garden that we know
of well to understand the story of
ulysses we need to talk to elizabeth but
princess dusk is here no longer snatched
away by that horrifying primeval human
and so i must ask
could there once more play the savior
an abyss was begat of the ancient beast
and threatens to swallow the whole of
ulysses
knight artorias came to stop this
but such a hero has neary a murmur of
dark without doubt he will be swallowed
by the abyss
overcome by its utter blackness
indeed
the abyss may be unstoppable
still
i have faith that princess dusk may be
rescued yet this prime evil human is
manus of the abyss the final boss of the
dlc and the thing that sucked us into
oolacile in the first place so our job
is to hunt manus down my main gripe with
the dlc is justification as technically
with the lord vessel we can just leave
so why do we need to worry about this
it's not an immersion breaking problem
but it is a shame while traveling to the
land of ooly seal you will come across
this coliseum-like structure which is
where we get to meet our next boss
artorius of the abyss artorius was one
of the four knights of gwyn the other
three are hawkeye goth who is sitting at
the top of the tower right next to the
coliseum karen who appears in the
coliseum after we defeat artorius and
the final light is orenstein each of
them were skilled in their own ways as
hawkeye used his powerful grepo to shoot
down dragons in fact he can actually
help us shoot down calamite who was the
last of the ancient dragons ornstein
also used his spear that was able to cut
through the scales of dragons with ease
and we can also see the spoils of his
war due to the amount of dragon heads
that exist in anor londo artorius is
also able to wield his greatsword with
incredible finesse and cairn used her
two daggers to cut down anyone who
opposed gwyn's rule but all of them
minus orenstein are way past their prime
which is a growing theme amongst the
entire series goth was imprisoned in
this tower with nothing left to do but
to make carvings he also couldn't use
his great bow anymore as all the dragons
have been wiped out so he has no purpose
karen may have had a deep love for
artoria says when we visit her she is
next to the grave she made for him and
asks if we can give her his soul if we
do she gives us her weapons and
continues to sit by the grave implying
that she no longer wants to be a knight
anymore and artorias came to ulucio an
attempt to stop the abyss from spreading
but ended up losing and being corrupted
himself his left arm is also dangling
which might suggest that it's broken
this is because he used his shield to
protect his wolf companion sith the same
sif from the main game although he is
much smaller in this dlc siff also has a
different intro if you do the dlc first
because oolacio is in the past so he'll
remember you in the present and it makes
killing him that much harder in regards
to sif it's possible that he doesn't
want us getting the covenant of the
abyss ring as that allows us to travel
through the abyss to kill the four kings
and given his owner's condition siff
probably doesn't want us to end up like
artorias the artorious bossfight was
actually really entertaining he was the
first boss that felt like the antithesis
of this game's combat most of the game's
pace has been very slow and methodical
but he has these fast attacks and very
few openers i do wish though that there
was at least an ounce of build up to
this fight as you can literally start
the dlc and be at the boss room in about
10 minutes i think having the player
traverse some of the areas that are
covered in these abyss creatures that
grow in number as we get closer to
artorias would have been great as it's
slowly leading us towards this person
responsible for all this death while
narratively it felt a bit too fast for
me the fight mechanically was great
after artorias we can explore the rest
of uliseo and we can see how much this
land has been affected by the abyss as
all the inhabitants have been infected
by this dark energy turning them into
these disgusting creatures eventually
we'll reach the bottom and this feeling
of fear starts to set in as the world
becomes darker and darker the further we
go down here in the chasm of the abyss
is where the darkness reaches its peak
and it's where these dark sprites of
humanity live these are very similar and
designed to the actual humanity we
consume in game this seems to be
humanity in a more physical form one
that is more exposed and not constricted
by the dark side at the foot of the
chasm is our final boss manus the father
of the abyss menace has an interesting
story apparently the people of ulysses
were tricked by a serpent who was
probably coth into digging manus grave
up in doing so it caused manus to go
wild and unleash his wrath upon them
according to his soul manus was once a
human but became father of the abyss
when his humanity went wild and now he
eternally seeks his broken pendant the
same pendant we had to find to start the
dlc it's unclear why he liked this
pendant so much but it was possibly
nostalgic to him or was given to him by
someone he loved and because this
pendant was so important to him he did
everything he could to get it back which
inevitably drove him to insanity it
seems that he got so desperate to find
the pendant that he pulled in random
people into this world as the npc
marvelous chester is clearly not from
this world and he even says so himself
he also kind of looks like the hunters
from bloodborne which is a nice
reference to the game the main question
many within the community have though is
who was manus before he became his
current deformed state well we really
don't know many have said it's the
furtive pygmy and i like that idea but i
think it's less interesting than that
many of the spells in this dlc say that
they were created by an oolacilian
sorcerer on the brink of madness i can't
help but think that this is perfect for
manus description one thing that is
interesting is that in the middle of the
arena is a grave with a humanity-shaped
hole so maybe manus was one of these
humanity sprites when he died or that
this is what he turned into when he died
regardless it's a very interesting
detail i also couldn't get any footage
of this as she disappears when you leave
the boss room but dusk apparently
appears out of manus when we kill him
meaning that he kidnapped her this may
confuse some people as dusk has been
sort of all over the place in this game
and due to her going from the past to
the present it sort of screws with the
time a bit it seems like she was sent
into our time somehow and was captured
by this golem she then disappears and
goes back into her time which then leads
to the abyss incident with the people of
oolacile artorias is then called to
defeat the abyss but fails and then we
get summoned into this world via manus
hand then save dusk and go back to the
present it's still a little confusing
and the world of dark souls is also very
confusing when it comes to time as
always during this fading of the fire
time is very convoluted because we can
summon people as phantoms and the time
sort of stops it's very confusing but
that's how i think it went down but with
man instead we have officially finished
the dlc however this won't be the last
time we'll hear of manus but that's for
dark souls 2. artorias of the abyss was
a great dlc while it does lack in
motivation and regards to the player the
actual story of the dlc was great it
provides us with a nice timeline of
events as well as more insight into the
abyss and its effects on the world and
while not known at the time it would
eventually set up the plot to dark souls
2. it is without a doubt a worthy
extension to the game's story but now we
can finally go to the kiln of the first
flame and determine the fate of lordran
the kiln is coated in ash and we can see
the spirits of those who followed gwyn
into the kiln walk around aimlessly as
we approach the first flame we have one
person in our way and that is the lord
of sunlight himself earlier i said gwyn
sacrificed himself to rekindle the flame
and he did but because of his lord
soul's power he was able to keep his
body but his mind was gone gwyn has gone
hollow and while i'm more than capable
of killing him myself i couldn't dare
start the fight without the guy who's
been by my side since the very beginning
solaire of astora is easily the most
well-known npc in the entire souls
franchise and his story is a perfect
representation of the mood this game is
trying to convey throughout the whole
game we've been meeting with npcs of all
kinds some with goals and others without
but none of them have managed to touch
my heart in a way that solaire and
siegmeyer did both of them had a goal in
mind one wants to find his sunlight and
the other wants to explore the world but
both are stuck sigmar always seems to be
getting himself caught in some situation
whether that be a locked gate he can
enter or a poison swap he can cross and
solaire can find his sunlight they both
willingly became undead in order to
achieve their goals and it tore me apart
to hear that sigmar couldn't see it
through sigmar prides himself on being a
knight of katarina and that he can
handle all of his troubles on his own
but with my help i showed him that he
wasn't a worthy knight after all and
that he always needed someone to rescue
him more often than not in these games
your assistance will lead to their death
so it's either converse with them and
enjoy their company knowing that they
will die because of you or distance
yourself from them knowing that while it
hurts it's better that they get to live
another day npcs of these games will
usually end up achieving a terrible fate
but this sadness makes the few times a
happy outcome occurs all the better
solaire wasn't able to find sunlight of
his own he became depressed and wondered
if this journey was really worth taking
conveying the tone of the entire game is
our journey and our struggle really
worth it in the end which is why i owed
it to him to make it right it may not be
the actual sun but the first flame could
be considered the sun so for one final
time i summoned solaire and we took down
lord gwyn
quinn's theme has such a fitting tune
all these bosses have these intense
sounds with loud music but gwen's is
such a simple piano
it's not intense it's almost sad in a
way that the most powerful man in the
world has been reduced to nothing and
what was supposed to be a glorious fight
between two warriors really isn't it
makes it all the more worse when you
realize that gwyn can be parried and
once you nail this timing down this
fight is a cake walk further showing how
far from grace he has truly fallen with
gwyn defeated we can now choose our
ending but we aren't the only one who is
able to choose since we managed to bring
solaire all the way to the end of the
game he was able to also fight gwyn in
his own world thanks to the convoluted
timelines of dark souls and it is
canonized that he succeeded and linked
the flame in his own world he became the
sunlight he was searching for and that
might be one of the greatest endings in
the entire franchise but while solaire
linked the flame that doesn't mean we
have to if we choose the age of fire the
world continues we rekindle the flame
and use ourselves as kindling to
continue this age of fire if we instead
choose to leave we let the flame
extinguish itself we join the primordial
serpents including koth and probably
frant and usher in an age of dark one
where humanity is at the top and we
ourselves are the ruler at least that's
what we think will happen like many
plots on the soul series this is once
again left up to interpretation we only
get to see the very beginning of our
choice so anything after is just pure
speculation who knows what will happen
after and who knows if our choice was
really the correct one that's always
been up to the player to decide but i've
always felt that these endings are about
comfort do we stay comfortable knowing
that in the age of fire we aren't on top
and might be mistreated due to our lack
of strength or do we take the risk and
see what the age of dark is about one
thing to note though is the
circumstances regarding these endings
fram says that the undead curse will be
cured if we go with the age of fire and
not even koth says anything about this
when we talk with him about it so does
that mean that we'll stay undead or at
least still have the risk of going
hollow in the age of dark furthermore
the age of fire was a time ruled by the
gods and they did what they could to
keep it that way but we killed them
everyone in anor londo that is a god is
either dead or gone gwyndolin is the
only one that canonically lives thanks
to dark souls 3. so even though an age
of fire can be seen as the age of gods
that might not be true anymore as we
took care of most of them so there is
positives and negatives both ways and
that's really been the point there's
never going to be a clear answer it's
just whatever you think is right as for
me i think an age of dark is the proper
way to go as we said in the intro the
world of dark souls is like a set of
operations things come and things go and
the age of dark should have followed
after the age of fire but due to gwyn
breaking the rules of the world that
didn't happen so i think in an attempt
to set things back on track before
further destruction an age of dark is
the way to go regardless of what happens
in this age of dark at the very least
things will transition back to the way
it was supposed to be however that might
not be the actual ending given the
future titles some have debated on
proper endings and given the status of
dark souls 3 linking the flame i think
is the real ending and is definitely the
most agreed upon as just about every
person in this game will speak about
linking the flame we only hear about the
age of dark from koth who we have to
jump through several hoops to just even
meet i can almost guarantee someone has
gone throughout the entire game and
didn't even know that an age of dark was
the real option because of how hidden it
is and while it's not my preferred
ending continuing the age of fire would
set in motion numerous events for us to
discover dark souls 1 was a fantastic
experience from start to finish and
while the road was a little bumpy
sometimes along the way its story
wrapped up wonderfully it's a game that
i recommend you play at least once in
your lifetime as you will never get to
experience something like this ever
again
but we're just getting started
but now we've made it to the outro thank
you all for watching today and i hope
you all enjoyed if you did please be
sure to like and subscribe if you're new
we still have quite a few souls games to
get through so get ready as we're going
to be going through dark souls 2 next
and i must say i'm honestly quite
excited and i hope you all are too to
wrap things up as always thank you to my
returning viewers for coming back to
another video and take care everyone
goodbye
[Music]
you